you know the possibility that we would
return was always there i didn't know if
a story would materialize that felt it
was worth telling but in this case it
but i'm an did monster
it's eight years ago right since since
the show's been off why is now kind of
the right time to bring this guy back i
think it has everything to do with how
much time has passed and that the story
hinges on the relationship between
dexter and his son and his son is now a
full-grown
young man or
almost young man i guess why now the
question the answer is ultimately we had
to wait for harrison to grow up you know
and i think you know taking this much
time away
allows the
return to the character feel like a bit
of a surprise but it hasn't been so much
time that people have completely like
put it so far in their review that
they don't even remember him i don't
know how to do this let's keep his head
up
i mean everything
how to be a father how to take care of
him how was it for you
reconnecting with him with with dexter
himself and also on that same note how
much and what has changed in him since
he's moved away it was a trip it was
really wild i didn't really know what to
expect but i i found that uh once once i
showed up and and we started shooting
that he was still very
very much alive you know he was still
very familiar he's obviously in a
completely different context and has
come a long way from where we left him
but he was still very like available to
me which was reassuring and creepy
um
the biggest difference is
the fundamental difference is that in
these in these eight years or near
decades since we left him he hasn't
killed anybody he's been abstinent he's
been
um dedicated to this sober life
and um has managed it managed it in his
very sort of isolated way and so
you know he's a guy who's who's dead to
himself as far as he's concerned but um
as you can imagine the cameras are
turning back on probably because he's
gonna come back to life many fans didn't
really feel they got the proper closure
with the ending of the of the series
how do you feel about it i totally get
people's dissatisfaction with the way
the show ended because it didn't really
end it just it just sort of left
us in this pretty unresolved uncertain
place
and
while i thought you know that it made
sense for the character to find himself
in that position you know and to put
himself in this apparent self-imposed
exile after
all the chaos at the end of the show
i totally get why it was pretty
unsatisfying if not like infuriating for
fans who had spent all this time and and
were longing for something that was uh
uh that you know answered some questions
or tied some things up or did something
that would the the finale didn't manage
to do but
you know if nothing else it did set the
stage for for what we've been up to over
the past several months making this new
this new show so maybe that's the silver
lining were you motivated at all to come
back to fulfill that fan need that fan
closure was that at all part or is this
just absolutely
no that's absolutely a part of it you
know i mean
you know i i think just as i knew that
the show didn't sit that well in its
finale with with viewers it didn't sit
that well with me i felt like i
owed it to
myself to explore it further if it came
up that it made sense and it did and
owed it to the character and owed it to
the fans for sure